[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
hey guys welcome to DC all-access live
from New York it's Comic Con we are
coming at you for the next two hours
with amazing guests with all the latest
news from around the world of DC and
right now that means the new Justice
League trailer prepare to have your
faces melted check it out it's my 10th
time watching it
[Music]
[Music]
I'll take that as a yes what the ring
[Music]
good morning after the death of Superman
violence acts of war and terrorism are
all on the rise I had a dream it was the
end of the world
you
I think it's something more something
darker
[Music]
we're asking people we'd unknown to risk
their lives strong man and strong as
alone never heard that it's not saying
that's the opposite of what the saying
is
divided we are not enough
worldly Superman
made in the promise
why I brought you together
ride ain't over yet man
okay
[Music]
Oh awesome as a bad thing oh that's your
oh sorry
it's your signal that means we have to
go now yeah it's so cool that was
awesome
okay so I have multiple favorite parts
but I'm gonna go through let's just say
uh pick one favorite moment for each of
you Whitney what was yours flame
parademons in the sky throne excited but
also just him anytime there's a shot of
him in the water looking so good he
looks like he looks like a very regal
hot sexy King what about for you Jason I
mean for me the shot it's the idea that
the team's coming together where Wonder
Woman leaps over the Batmobile and
knocks out her a couple pair of demons
as the flash runs by the idea that we're
finally seeing this team together and
that they can work together is so
exciting it's so good I every time I
watch it I have a different favorite
moment because I remember in the Batman
V Superman film when we first got
introduced to Wonder Woman and she's
fighting and she looks up and has that
smirk and I was like oh my god that's
she loves the fight and so having that
little smirk in this trailer was it just
made yeah if I could say scene wise like
what it's gotten me excited for about
the movie the final little scene that we
get with flash Wonder Woman and Bruce
Wayne obviously it's a funny moment but
seeing the interaction between all of
them that tiny moment where Wonder Woman
is like kind of laughing and Ezra being
like what Batman and he's or Bruce and
Bruce is just like okay it's so charming
and I can't wait to see their
interactions like that's what it's a
nice thing that the flash is sort of a
Batman fan boy yeah he's eyes like all
of us I think that the dynamic is gonna
be so fun because they all have
different like different things that
they bring to the table
obviously flash being the fanboy and the
humor I like that moment with cyborg and
Aquaman as well because we haven't
really seen
we're gonna get with this version of
cyborg that yeah we got a nice little
moment with Lois Lane in the beginning
Oh dropping that dirt there's plenty to
talk about guys but this is just the
beginning folks we have a whole show
coming up including Edie Boone talking
about injustice to later yes I love
injustice - there's a ton happening at
Comic Con so make sure you're following
us on Instagram and Twitter at DC Comics
so you don't miss a thing we even
mention the dream sequence looks so
handsome in fact DC's presence is so
huge here I'm still on the trailer I
can't these presence is so big that is
invading the rest of New York and I got
to go to Times Square for a
one-of-a-kind
Justice League experience check it out
[Music]
so we are here with Geoff Johns and
Gimli obviously we're here at the AT&T
store in Times Square can you guys tell
everybody watching what we're doing here
I mean you can kind of feel out costumes
behind us but I got a little idea what
we're here to talk about the world's
greatest superhero yes the Justice
League yeah Batman Superman Wonder Woman
Aquaman Aquaman cyborg what do you guys
think it is about the Justice League
that makes them the best superhero team
I mean I think they're just the most
iconic superheroes existence you know
everyone knows you're Batman and
Superman at one over R and they're about
to be flash and I'll plant a cyborg so
it doesn't get bigger than the justices
for me I think it's in all the
characters come from kind of different
points of life that from points of view
but they set aside those differences and
come together and as a team they can do
more than they could individually so
yeah that's kinda like the power of
unity the power of unity the power of
diversity yeah absolutely and obviously
you guys have worked with these ìcome
iconic characters for so long what is it
about them that you guys really get
excited about specifically is there
anything I mean as a team their
interactions I think oh yes everyone
does have a different viewpoint like
Barry Allen the flash is in awe of
Batman and Wonder Woman in Aquaman's not
all of that I don't want to win and I
think there are different perspectives
on why they do with it what justice
means and how to
save the world yeah that's a lot of fun
I think artistically speaking obviously
I mean they're the world's greatest
superheroes they have amazing powers you
have king of the seven seas you've got
man that lives in a bat cave you've got
a man can fly a woman that's a warrior I
mean there's amazing things to draw and
so it's a lot of fun as an artist and
just hearing you guys talk about it so
casually like yeah you know Batman Bruce
Lanham and right and wrong these grants
are so long but you come to an event
like this you're Batmobiles outside and
hens are lined up and the costumes are
here do you guys still geek out
absolutely or say these concept cars
beautiful so yeah we're here for the car
do you wanna pick one I'm gonna I want
to sit inside the the MIRR say well I'm
gonna drive the bathroom I've already
driven in back Batmobiles before so I
think well I mean it's so interesting
because the characters are so iconic but
also the vehicles are too what do you
think it is about the Batmobile or a
Mercedes concept car that people and
fans get so pumped about where it's like
you want to get in it you want to drive
it around
well let's grew up with it you have you
seen it and then it becomes a reality
that's why school to see this right did
become a reality they kind of go up the
comic pages and enter into our life Mike
I gotta say I think that's the biggest
thing I'm excited about is just seeing
them all together on the big screen what
is it that you guys are the most excited
for fans to see when
without I'm excited for them to meet
this original flashes might been my
favorite character since I was a kid and
Ezra Miller as Barry Allen is pretty
killer I think the return of Wonder
Woman for me I mean she was awesome in
her own standalone movie that hints at
the chemistry between her and Superman
and Batman and that maybe Superman and
now he's on these other characters how
does she interact with Aquaman how did
you interact with a character like the
flash so that's the kind of stuff and
since you guys are so close to it I
always got to try for a little gem a
little secret
are there any moments that you guys can
talk about them might be a scene or
something just to hint at for people to
keep a close eye out for ever scenes
involves Aquaman and you'll know it when
you see it well thank you guys so much I
know the fans are outside waiting to get
to meet you and have you signed the
books that they have come to love so
much thanks so much for hanging out now
I'm gonna follow you this - when you go
to sit in the car do you think they'll
let me sure Robin I'll be in the
Mercedes so you guys I'll co-pilot in
both it's fine
[Music]
you face the true god of thunder your
power cannot touch me to the nether
realm with you
[Music]
another backdrop you're getting struck
by Black Lightning you're headed for the
cemetery
your plow our stones now feel my full
power
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back we have with us the man
responsible for your thumb blisters and
wounded pride the mastermind of
injustice to Ed Boon thank you so much
for coming to hang out with us thank you
for having me I was always fun I am so
excited because every time we get to
talk to anybody from injustice it's
usually about new characters new super
moves all that good stuff so let's get
right into it and talk to me about
Raiden coming into the game yeah Raiden
that you know that the timing it seems
that the stars seem to have aligned you
know Raiden is being introduced in
injustice on the 25th you know 25 year
anniversary of Mortal Kombat's that we
thought there was just something you
know we had to we had to do it and you
know it's always fun to have like kind
of like these guest characters we had
sub-zero and we've also had you know in
our games just a number of guest
appearances it's always fun to see those
kind of novel things and reign just kind
of add to that list how do you guys
decide because obviously there are so
many great characters to pull from but
do you guys listen to what the fans are
asking for is there a list that you're
like I really want to get that one in
the game I really want to get this one
in probably 80% of the characters is
something that we get a feeling for like
the fans just their feedback on social
media and everything like that and then
there's a couple that we were just like
you know us personally which like no
he's gonna be that game dr. fate was one
of them I remember and Atrocitus was one
of them as well so it's kind of a
combination of what we want but mainly
what players want
so for Raiden was that one that came
from the fans or was that one where
you're like that one was us again it was
it was something about you know the 25th
anniversary of Mortal Kombat we just
really thought that it was um it was
almost like destined to be yeah I feel
like it's one of those characters that
I'm sure was not easy to not hard to
sell to get people on board yeah yeah
exactly you know there's there's so many
great DC characters and so you know
there's a certain amount of people who
are like you know when they see someone
who's not from the DC Universe they were
like you know that means my beast boy
didn't get in or something like that but
at the end of the day you know like you
know Black Lightning is his you know
alternate you know kind of personality
so so it'll be fun to see that to you
thing people always want to know about
because we can even like watching the
content right now it's like we want to
know about their fighting style we want
to know about their super moves so what
can you tell us about raiden raiden
again he is you know he actually takes
you back into an arena that is like a
Mortal Kombat universe it's really great
and that you know he brings you up to
the moon kind of like Batman did I know
and gives like his version of it where
you see the Mortal Kombat dragon the
dragon appears and it slams you onto the
ground so it's a really cool like you
know there nods to different parts of
previous games and DC and everything
it's a great kind of a combination of
normal combat in DC how does that feel
for you because obviously hearing you
say 25th anniversary 25th anniversary
Batman the Animated Series and Mortal
Kombat and it's just one of those things
where it was so influential for age
groups like mine and a lot of people
here how does that feel for you it makes
me feel old
first of all 25 years the the other one
is it iconic and then it also you know
and again there's something about you
know Harley Quinn being 25 Batman Anna's
animated series Mortal Kombat you know
is there's something about this year
that's so I have to ask because this is
DC all-access we always want juicy
gossip new things coming out can you
tease the fans with anything else for
injustice - well we recently teased oh
we didn't tease it we gave it away but
we give it at ease gameplay trailer of
the atom
has some really unique gameplay and
that's that's always a lot of fun and
there's more to come I think people are
going to be just we have probably our
biggest surprise coming as far as
characters I can't say what it is but I
can tell you it'll most likely be our
you will then hint is you will be
familiar with this with this character
these care that doesn't oh okay we got
B's kid that's a little bit I was like
you'll be familiar with the character
I'm like yeah I would hope so these
characters but I'll take it I'll take it
not put you on the fire too long
so another great thing I think is just
the game world in general the
tournaments that are going on now what
is that like for you getting to go to
see these tournaments and see all these
players come out and have so much
passion for the game it's amazing you
know our goal with making this game was
not only to serve DC fans and you know
NetherRealm fans but also you know the
competitive eSports part you know
fighting games you know one on one it
really lends himself to you know
competition an actual you know like
prized prize money and everything like
that so we're really serious about you
know having Mortal Kombat B and eSport
and be something that people can play
competitively get good at and stuff like
that so that's that really fills in that
void in terms of that was one of the
goals that we want what is the
experience like though actually being at
one of those tournaments cuz obviously
I've watched that online I've never been
to one of them but I feel like the
energy must just be it's like the energy
of a sporting event
it's literally everybody's cheering
everybody has their favorite players you
know there's personalities there's a
little bit of wrestling in there you
know it's like it's such a great you
know you know emerging category of
sports so if you were to be in one of
the tournaments who would your go-to
character be my go-to character will
probably be Atrocitus and I probably
lose the first time are there any
internal competitions going on in the
office where you guys just are like
alright we're gonna try out these
characters and who is the best I feel
like I know it's not you because you
said you would die in maybe oh yeah yeah
you know artists our designers our QA
analysts are just 10 times better than
any of us so they play the game yeah 10
hours a day you know and so it's the QA
guys would easily win so there is no
real internal competition going on
you're like we're not we're not dumb
enough to play against them for any kind
of money or anything like that
there is something though even when you
watch people game are there moments
where you're you don't even know how
incredible these games are gonna look
once you get someone like that playing
yeah that's exactly it it's it's kind of
like you know like whoever invented you
know billiards or or baseball or or you
know you can never envision how good
somebody's going to get yeah
these games and so they do things that
we all look at each other and like Oh
Batman can do that oh I didn't know that
you know Harley can do that and so it's
just really fun seeing players just
uncover things that are in the game that
you know we would never guess they just
keep leveling it up so use that uncover
and it just immediately made me think is
there anything in the games that fans
could look for maybe hidden easter eggs
or anything
there's a bunch you know there's a bunch
of things in our in our backgrounds that
we put little clues and everything you
know there's a nod to mortal kombat and
one of the theater wonders if you keep
hitting up players
against the wall the letters fall and
then the remaining letters they finish
him you know so no mortal kombat a
little bit a little clues scattered
about the game on I love that I love it
so much
well thank you so much for coming to
chat and happy 25th anniversary to moral
Kombat I'm gonna have to play some
injustice to and do that just so I can
see finish him thank you you guys this
train just keeps going and we're only
getting started so stick around because
we will be right back with even more
finish him not really cuz we're gonna be
back
thanks for that light now this just got
a whole lot more interesting
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
we are here with Marguerite Bennett
writer of bombshells United which is an
awesome twist on the DC Universe how are
you Marguerite I am fantastic and very
happy to be here thank you so much for
taking the time I know you're very very
busy walking around the con let's get
right into it I'm what is currently
going on in bombshell
oh goodness so when we got the the you
know the news that we're gonna get to
relaunch with the new number one for the
bombshells universe and get so you know
bring in so many new readers and
continue the adventures for people who
had been following the series of the
past two years I knew I wanted to do
something very unexpected and since
we're given this fantastic opportunity
within an alternate history and you know
we had the chance to sort of refocus the
thesis of the series you know in the
very first series you know it was just
sort of on a world building and you know
we had all these different genres in
play you know one dirham was a war story
that one was this like cheesy radio
adventure real aqua woman was a romance
the town was a horror film and in
refocusing with the new number one we
had you know this this ongoing theme
this idea of second chances you have a
new chance on number one you have a new
chance to bring people into the to the
universe for the first time and I kept
on thinking about you know that
alternate history and what would you do
if you had a second chance now within
your own life you know within the larger
global um you know history of the world
you know so we wanted to go back through
the major turning point some of this era
and examine with you know what you knew
then what you know now where could you
have gone differently at the crossroads
and so we're beginning actually right in
the homeland you know we're beginning um
you know we opened up with Wonder Woman
fighting the American military and we
draw back you know out of the Arizona
desert to show her fighting against
these massive tanks you know during the
first day of Japanese internment and so
it becomes you know it launches us with
this whole idea that this is going to be
the world you knew in the world you have
to take responsibility for and you know
the exploration of what our world could
have become you know had you made a
different choice and the idea that you
don't just have to be a hero in the
battlefield but the idea of you know
civilian heroism the idea that you're in
a cultural crisis of conscience and what
choice do you make and how does that
change the world around
I love that somebody's idea of second
chances was that inspired by anything in
particular
oh really it was just you know coming
back with the new number one is you know
how do you redefine this world just sort
of you know the idea I know that world
were to gets held up very often you know
almost the point that it's that's a
trope to discuss um but it was just you
know people say you know well this is
what I would have done if I was in that
era but you know never again as always
right now and if what you're doing now
is what you would have been doing then
you know what you get everyone gets one
lifetime and it's up to you to decide if
you're going to do with it
so on that bombshell to set in the 40s
but it's still incredibly modern why do
you think that is well you know I feel
when I was a child world where to seems
so distant all of history seems so
distant and the older I get the more
exigent the little closer the past feels
to me and so again it wasn't my
attention to attain or write a story
with any parallels but I think that it's
just exactly that is that you know
history does repeat itself and you don't
intend to be writing things that turn
out to seem a little bit on the nose but
you know just by the the natural trends
of you know when these characters were
created and just you know the just the
patterns and storytelling the patterns
in our histories anything so where does
the art go from here oh goodness
so we get to work with a fantastic
artist on this first arc especially
Marguerite Savage and then from here
we're going to explode out to different
theatres of war we're going to be
visiting the South Pacific we're going
to fascist Spain we're gonna revisit
North Africa you know where we're going
all over creation so it's really
wonderful that is awesome and you also
write Batwoman which is incredible it's
so good where is it going from here oh
gosh
so um number seven I don't know if
everyone else know about Fernando Blanco
the artist on the issue or if I was the
only person sleeping on his art it's
like my lord I mean I turn in script
pages like four panels of page II turn
them back with nine it's all rich with
horror most of this brand-new scarecrow
arc and so if you have been following
the series so far you can jump on with
issue seven that just came out a couple
weeks ago and so we're taking that woman
into the middle of the Sahara and it's
this massive just like radiation poison
drug trip it's the worst and most rotten
parts of her psyche and yeah so it's a
bat woman versus scarecrow and it's all
about like you know her damn
and her family and monsters in body har
and it's just it's out of this world
amazing anytime you use the words like
psychedelic and nightmare thank you so
much taking my [ __ ] where can people
find you on social media I am an evil
marguerite across the board so twitter
tumblr instagram gmail yeah i look
forward to talking with y'all not same
evil coming up later we have Bruce Timm
and Alan Burnett talking about the 20th
anniversary of Batman the Animated
Series but first we have to take a quick
break
don't go anywhere we will be right back
Church Johnny really
unconsecrated otherwise I'd have a hard
time setting foot in there and so are
they but what's that bloody smell smells
like [ __ ]
yep that would be me can it make good on
its promise oh that that was a lie to us
and I feel terrible about it in what
share see
it'll smear flesh I was hoping that he
would promised me a feast Constantine
and you have delivered what is this
particular slave you five seek to usurp
a land that rightfully mine
I will stop you consume you body and
soul for you
I could have never found these five on
my own never helped them here without
your magics we live to serve now what
are you waiting for
finish your dinner
[Music]
going somewhere
[Music]
wally west is back and a man in blue is
coming after you do you hear that
ticking that means it's time to play
beat the Doomsday Clock beat the
Doomsday Clock is a game where fans try
to answer five questions about the DC
Universe correctly in 30 seconds and
believe me it's harder than it sounds
alright let's bring in our first
contestant right here if you would stand
right there sir please tell us your name
and where you from I'm John wit and I'm
from Minneapolis you have an amazing
Batman costume now I'm his old chum
already all right I love this now would
you like to play for Joker questions or
Superman questions
let's do Joker all right let's go for
Joker you will have five seconds to
answer all 30 questions correctly do you
understand yes all right let's start the
Doomsday Clock go who is Joker's nemesis
me that rent complete this title Batman
the killing blank joke
correct what is Joker's real name it's
unknown that is correct what actor
portrayed Joker in the Suicide Squad
movie Jared Leto that is correct
Joker loves to wear what color purple
we're green you've got all five
questions correct Batman congratulations
you get this Doomsday Clock pin and they
you can save the world you can't save
the world alone has your own symbol on
there Batman thank you so much for
playing you look amazing
exit write that back to the Batcave
Batman you have to protect the citizens
of Gotham alright let's bring in our
next contestant right now he is a little
scary he's a little looks like he's made
of hay and barley how come right here
sir please take that microphone for me
what's your name where you from Martin
from Canada Martin from Canada I hope
you can breathe in that mask
you cannot okay but you can still play
the game and breathe fear oh he's got
puns of his own I like this alright
would you like to choose questions about
Superman or DC TV Superman alright we're
gonna go as Superman questions you
thirty seconds to answer all five
questions correctly to win amazing
prizes are you ready yeah all right
let's start the Doomsday Clock go Clark
Kent works at what newspaper Daily
Planet that is correct named three
powers that Superman has three ice
breath laser vision x-ray vision that is
correct where did Clark Kent grow up
Smallville
that is correct Superman thought which
Kryptonian general and Man of Steel
General Zod that is correct
what is the name of Superman's dog
Krypto that is correct you've got all
five questions right you get this
amazing Doomsday Clock pin and the
Justice League t-shirt as well but I
don't think it will match your mask or
scare Batman please exit right that way
sir thank you so much for playing all
right let's bring in our next contestant
do not adjust your monitors yes she is
the color that she is supposed to be
what is your name where are you from
name is Chelsea I'm Orange County
California I loved that you were
challenging our color perceptions right
now
you look fantastic all right now you
have two choices would you rather have
questions about Green Arrow or DC TV
okay you will have 30 seconds to answer
all five questions correctly to win the
prize of Harlequin you cannot steal them
you shifty criminal hmm okay are you
ready ready as I'll ever be
okay let's start the Doomsday Clock go
what is Green Arrow's main weapon
analyst that is correct what actor
portrays Green Arrow and the CW show
Jason Jason or Mel that is incorrect
what does it mean arrows real name
Oliver Queen that is correct what bird
name superheroes green arrows love
interest that canary
that is correct true or false Oliver
Queen has been elected mayor yes that is
correct what actor plays Green Arrow in
the CW show even the mouth that is
correct you got it yeah you know five
questions correct Oh excellent you win
this joobs they call you pin and this
amazing Justice League t-shirt don't
show it to the Joker I pray I'm afraid
he might get angry if he sees it yeah
but don't go anywhere because I have to
keep you hostage just like dr. Manhattan
has kept us all hostage because everyone
out there there's still a ton more to
come we've got two of the geniuses
behind Batman the Animated Series Bruce
Timm and Alan Burnett couple to do is to
help create this lovely lady
joining us in just a few minutes so
don't go
heads up people the Reich is the
refugees on the run and they're heading
this way hold the line here we need to
give them a chance to make it safety get
airborne gentlemen
cannot chance Reisman accessing data you
must
[Music]
the androids brain give it to me
not a chance
[Music]
for so many fans myself included Batman
the Animated Series is Batman the show
turns 25 this year and right now I am
here with Bruce Timm and Alan Burnett
there to tell us everything I'm gonna
ask you guys everything everything okay
we've got five minutes to get everything
in it's gonna happen
the show thank you guys so much for
coming Berta's let's just get right into
it obviously we're here to celebrate the
25th anniversary of the series how crazy
is that for you guys did you ever think
it would get to this point when you
start it we're you're like 25 years
later there's gonna be fans who are
still chomping at the bit to watch it
and hear you guys talk about it no never
never thought I mean you know it sounds
a modest but I what we did the show I
kind of guessed that it was probably
gonna be a hit I mean not just because
the show was good was good but back then
coming off of the the this is a huge
mega success of the first Tim Burton
Batman movie Batman was just huge back
then so I was like I had a feeling this
show would would do great no matter
whether what we did on the show or not
but I was proud of what we did I thought
we did the show properly and but I never
I never looked forward to this day
there's like 25 years of past and there
there was nothing else like it you know
and and I think we both knew people
wanted this yeah absolutely so when it
when the Pima hit it wasn't a big
surprise but was it was a pleasure yeah
it was it was yeah pleasant not pleasant
non surprise I think it's crazy because
you go back and you look through so many
of the voice actors who were a part of
the show and it's not just quote-unquote
voice actors they're heavy hitters that
are just actors in general as voice
actors are as well but there were people
that I've heard that just people started
coming to you guys and asking I want to
be a part of the show can I do a voice
for the show yeah that's what we were
told which is cool and it's you know
entre Romano was the one who kept
pushing that Jerry Cassaday yeah yeah
it's a casting director voice director
and yeah we did we didn't a pay chat and
variety there must have been a hundred
names of primetime yet
actors had never done it before yeah but
one actor I actually heard them say that
was Jobeth Williams she came to do a
walk-on part for us and she's said she
was yeah I honestly I've never even
heard of your show just forgive me show
you but but my kids watch it like every
day and so when they heard that was up
for this part he said oh yeah mom you
gotta do it you gotta do it it's like
okay so yeah whatever works you know I
love that there was also and boom came
up and was talking about injustice to
today and he was like it's it's the 25th
anniversary of Harley Quinn as well and
I was like and the animated series and I
was like Pat created on the animated
series thank you and you walk around
comic-con as Harley I think it's still
one of the most cosplay characters how
does that make you guys feel that
there's characters that people just
relate to so much that just feel like
they've been a part of the fabric of DC
from the very beginning it's it's cool I
mean it's a cliche but I have lots of
people in there like early 30s who come
up to me and say oh yeah you were my
childhood and it's just like wow okay
that's weird but but yeah with like
Harley it's like III was not really
aware how popular she was becoming in
real time over the years I would go to
conventions and I'd see a lot of people
cosplaying as Harley and then every year
it seemed like there was more and more
people cosplaying as Harley and and all
different kinds of Harley and and a
couple years ago somebody I was giving
an interview and the guy said yeah she's
like she's like one of the top four or
most popular characters in comics now
and I went huh what yeah they're like
yeah yeah Jim Jim Lee called her the
fourth pillar of the DC Animated
universe is like wow that's crazy so
true did you do you feel seeing Harley
so funny and Arleen Sorkin did the voice
for us awesome and she was awesome and
and the voice had a lot to do with that
and I love it one obviously you talk
about voice actors who are part of this
project and I always joke of course I
love the Star Wars films but Mark Hamill
is the Joker first and foremost for me
um every time I hear his voice I can't
help but think of that
so for Mark Hamill to Kevin Conroy what
was it like or do you guys have any
specific memories doing stuff with them
no it was just always fun I mean and and
we aundrea was always really good about
trying to get as many of the actors in
the room at the same time sometimes
nowadays when we're doing the movies
that everybody is so busy that sometimes
we have to pick them up individually but
back then it was like always just like
getting an awesome room full of talent
and it would be kind of funny cuz some
actors would be a little bit like oh
yeah I'm doing this cartoon oh why am I
here what for they walk in the room it's
like oh my god there's ed asner you know
they become like fanboys themselves
there were auditions done and I got a
list of auditions and there were names
there there's mark Campbell I'm gonna
really mark am you think star wars you
think yeah you know yeah the leading man
type and it's just not yeah yeah it's
knock you out so awesome
it's one of those voices now that
literally like I said every time I hear
him I still just think Joker he was
literally one of the hardest voices to
cast for the show
I mean Batman was hard too we had a
really hard time went through hundreds
of people before we found Kevin but for
mark it was like we probably went
through yet dozens and dozens and dozens
of Joker's and everybody was doing these
weird cartoon voices and stuff and then
we got Tim Curry and he recorded first
four or five episodes and then we had to
replace him for variety of reasons and
then and then when Mark came in it was
just like oh my thank God slam dunk you
know it's like like within like to work
you know two lines I was like we're good
we're don't have to audition anymore he
sounds exactly what you expect them to
say yeah
he's got the the tenor and the lilt yes
just great well I gotta ask being a part
of the show and working on it so much
one do each of you have a favorite
episode or an episode that really
resonated with you obviously it's like
asking to pick your favorite kid but
it's hard alright did we did like 80 of
them so it's tough
you go first well I loved the story for
perchance to dream which was the story
about Bruce Wayne wakes up one day and
he's no longer Batman and parents are
still alive parents are still alive and
what's going on I love that story
because it's a pure Batman story no
other superhero could tell that story so
that's one of my favorites I got toppers
I mean the one I always kind of go back
to is again not probably the deepest
story or the most you know revolutionary
but the very first episode we did the
man bed episode on leather wings I mean
that was our the very first episode that
we we put into production it was the
first time we recorded with our cast it
was the first time we saw the footage
come back from overseas and it was just
like oh it works thank God we didn't
know if it was gonna work and it worked
it was the first time we heard Shirley
Walker's amazing music I got to go to
the scoring stage and hear this the the
score live so I have a lot of really
deep fond memories about that episode so
I think all the fans have really deep
fond memories of the show as well
I love rewatching ever so literally in
the background just on I'm like I'll
throw those on so thank you guys so much
for creating such an awesome show for
the DC fans and I know that room is
gonna be packed tonight you guys have
your 20th anniversary panel today yes if
you're still here at the con make sure
you check it out and you guys there's so
much more DC all-access life to come so
we will be right back don't move thank
you guys
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
first of all we're going to talk about
imaginary fiends this is a book that's
already been announced out there that
Tim Seeley is doing for us Tim why don't
you talk about that a little bit
imaginary fiends is it's a horror book
kind of me going back to doing what I
think I do best which is a mean badass
girl in a monster comics that's kind of
what I started out doing so it's meeting
to go back to do that and it's a girl
who's put in jail because she was
convinced by her imaginary friend to
stab someone and when she gets out of
jail she's conscripted by the FBI to
help them find other imaginary friends
who convince people to do bad things
people have asked me is this graphic
novel series meant to be a commentary on
modern politics present-day politics and
I would tell them no we started thinking
about this long before the election but
it is a story that is timely and
unfortunately it is a story that is
timeless other lines book about an
emotionally needy woman trying to build
a relationship with her narcissistic
overbearing mother both of whom happened
to be interdimensional bounty hunters
it's the sort of the the elderly mother
who once was the it girl who still
thinks she's kind of the girl but she's
not she's just a mess and her daughter
who is this buttoned-down pragmatist who
just wants to get the job done but in
order to get the job done this one time
she needs her mom to come with her the
idea of like taking such well-trod
ground as sci-fi and trying to bring in
designs that are just a little bit
different and something that looks a
little bit fresh or weird where you
might pick it up and be like cuz know
I've never worked vertigo so sending the
designs off I was like are they just
gonna sort of call the police on me and
be like she's clearly unhinged in maybe
we should watch out on this one with a
deathbed it's about this guy in named
Antonio Luna who at one point in his
life was kind of this like Howard Hughes
sort of character who would travel a
world and kept reinventing himself like
he would get bored with the life he had
and reinvent himself he kept he would be
a monster hunter he was a baseball
player he was a rock star
he was a soldier like he did all these
different things with sometimes he I
you'd be like a dinosaur hunter like he
would do all these different crazy
things and eventually one day he just
disappeared just disappear off the face
of the planet it's been 20 years that
he's been in hiding and suddenly he
wants to tell his story he hires a
publisher to send a reporter out to meet
him to basically record his biography
because the most important thing to Luna
is his story that is the thing that he
feels is most important part of his life
is this legacy the story is leaving
behind we're doing JLA and Doom Patrol a
crossover that I'm co-writing with
Gerard and we're gonna have some other
people involved in it as well which I'll
talk about called milk Wars and I was
saying this is that character that
character is the the progenitor of milk
Wars milkman man these specials are just
like every time the scripts come in we
read them and there's some of the
wildest and most creative things that
have happened I think in DC Comics we're
finding new rules to break but that's
the way that you know that you're
pushing the limits every time you get a
script in I texted Gerard just tell me
what milk Wars was in one sentence and
he said it was milk Wars in one sentence
so 22 girl is basically the question
what if you're an immortal who wants to
die what do you do and then someone
shows up and says hey how about we
destroy the universe and then you go
yeah it's a pretty good idea that would
work so it's a really light fun yeah
it's super light
at the same time it's also just like her
just like dealing with her intense
depression trying to figure out a way to
not basic try to figure out a way to
like keep living I'm sort of at the same
time next year is the 25th anniversary
of vertigo
[Applause]
that's a pretty big deal and so to
celebrate not only are we doing great
new books like this but we are we're
going to be launching a lot of new books
next year that we're already working on
that now I'm sorry I can't talk about
them yet but trust me when I say that
vertigo is going to be a very exciting
place to be next year and to celebrate
the 25 years of vertigo what we're doing
in addition to all the new books and all
the new stuff we haven't announced we're
also going to be doing a great big
hardcover Vertigo 25th anniversary
special that'll be out in July of next
year and there will be new material in
it and interviews and backstories and
lofts things from all of the 25 years of
Vertigo's publishing history hey guys
welcome back to the show writer ray Fox
is here to tell us all about his new
series Ragman thank you for joining us
right thank you for having me okay so
for the uninitiated what is Ragna who is
Right Ragman is like a guy who grew up
in the slums of Gotham City went off
became a combat soldier came home and
found himself involved in a crazy
supernatural mess and becomes a really
wonderful great hero awesome so what can
we expect in issue number one in issue
number one you're gonna see how he
became who he is so there's gonna be
some like far-flung combat situations
and then you're gonna see him in those
pseudo rags that the fans know well
fighting demons and monsters right away
right out of the gate so is he does he
have a main antagonist who is he up
against primarily oh man Ragman is kind
of up against all the forces of hell
that's his main antagonist you know he's
got a fight big fight big or a fight
home that's what they say right um okay
so this is a reimagining correct how are
you retelling this room
yeah it's actually I have been saying
it's more like a reintroduction than a
reimagining like it where we're sort of
folding in all the best aspects of
Ragman from the past but we're
introducing him to readers new just in
case there's new readers who have never
read about him before so I mean we start
the story off from the start we show you
who he is and how he became what he is
but it's not like a crazy reboot in
Gotham City we'll definitely see some
familiar characters
well I'll spoil one thing in the second
issue you're gonna see bat woman she is
great okay so um describe the art in
Ragman oh man Inaki Miranda did the art
and it is gorgeous and dark and crazy
it's like it's like poetry and madness
and and blood and everything I would
ever want in a DC book basically a lot
of things are very metal actually so
what drew you initially to tell me the
story oh right
I'm unabashedly a fan of the dark weird
characters of the DC Universe and I
actually pitched Ragman over and over at
DC yeah and this was sort of like the
right time for it to hit and yeah it's
just I'm the guy that I like the ghosts
and monsters and demons and he fits
perfectly happy a little horror nerd it
makes me it makes my heart me too
awesome well what are you up to for the
rest of the con you know what I'm
talking Ragman everywhere I can go
that's drag man man get on it guys drag
man thank you so much for taking the
time guys New York Comic Con isn't even
close to being over we still have a ton
more show for you so stay put Jack Kirby
would have celebrated his 100th birthday
on Monday and DC has released a series
six one-shot specials this month in
order to celebrate the milestone first
up is the New Gods special which sees
the evil Kalibak enslave the bug colony
in a plot to take over New Genesis what
Orion won't stand for it and a bloody
brawl between the brothers decides which
of darkseid sons holds the most power
the newsboy legion and the boy commandos
special is set during world war two and
it brings kirby's KITT gangs together to
stop a coup and take down a fascist
traitor next the Sandman special sends
Kirby's 1970s creation on to adventures
in one the monsters from the young boys
dreams threatened to invade reality and
the other is about remembering loved
ones through your dreams both are
tributes to the king that will warm any
Kirby fans heart in Manhunter special
number one Paul Kirk has transformed
himself into a masked vigilante but
crime becomes so rampant bet he can't
contain it without help enter the
superhero duo Sandman and Sandy and
strap in for an adventure with some
Golden Age classics starting today you
can check out the black racer and Shiloh
Norman special as mr. miracle Shiloh
regularly escapes his own demise but the
god of death soon catches up to him and
Shiloh leads the black racer on a
death-defying chase across the universe
and finally Darkseid special number one
stars everyone's favorite all-powerful
overlord he's on the hunt for a group of
children that escaped from granny
goodness orphanage but one of the kids
is more than the lord of apocalypse
bargain for these one shots are all
equally fun moving and surprising and
are a perfect tribute to Jack Kirby's
unparalleled contribution to comics make
sure you check out the Darkseid special
and the black racer and Shiloh Norman
special today along with any others you
might have missed happy reading and
we'll see you next time
hey guys new challengers is a brand new
series from Scott Snyder and Andy Cooper
and they're here to give us all the
inside info you guys thank you so much
for being here oh thank you very much
it's been great it's a it really is like
New York is one of the craziest ones so
you have to sort of prepare yourself but
once you get in it it's it's huge fun
yeah you definitely have to mentally get
into af because it's so crowded but it's
a lot of fun it's a lot it's a crazy
cool energy so tell us all about who the
new challengers are yeah well
challengers the unknown is one of my
favorite series from you know a long
time since I was a kid and when we got I
actually pitched it to vertigo when I
first got to DC so it's something I've
been dying to do for a very long time
and what we wanted to do was sort of
embrace the spirit of the original that
kind of crazy Kirby esque adventure
exploratory energy and and apply it to
something that was modern so the way
it's meant to almost feel like a cross
between like adventures in space and
losts you know what I mean so basically
the challengers are there are four new
characters and essentially the book
opens with one of them who is a police
officer in a neighborhood in Gotham
being killed because the heroes are
fighting kind of a giant space alien up
above and you only see them as these
tiny kind of these tiny figures and it's
almost like a street level view of it
and what happens is when she wakes up
she finds herself in challengers
mountain with a tattoo on her arm of an
hourglass it's going down like this and
then this guy called the professor is
there he's got his brain like in a jar
and he's sort of like you're one of the
challenges the unknown you have to go on
a mission now or that thing's gonna run
out you're gonna die so it's meant to be
sort of completely out of control
bonkers fun but it's got one of the
things I love about it is that
challengers always had these big sort of
mysteries to them so it's got this huge
overarching mythology that goes all the
way back to the beginning of the DCU and
forward so we're really really proud of
it like I can't tell you how excited I
am to work with this guy I've been but
we've been friends a while and we've
only gotten to work together on an issue
here issue there and now to be able to
do something with him and to take
inspiration from his work is just a huge
joy here I can't I can't really add that
much more to it I always want them to
work with him and even after this we're
going
can you continue to work yeah it's
really really exciting a challengers is
just big I guess kind of like metal big
bombastic that is fun stuff let's talk
about the art because I want to know all
about the character design and what your
direction was in that well the character
design is kind of based off of what was
originally done didn't want to veer too
much from it want to keep it sort of
simple as far as they're designed the
costume designs but the the page layouts
and the the compositions are kind of
getting complex a little bit more than
what I did on Dark Knight you know every
kind of project lends to its own its
kind of its own animal so I'm kind of
feeling my way through every project
they start you kind of feel your way
through and you can get your footing and
your bearings and everything but this
one's coming together actually I didn't
even tell Scott this yet it's coming
together really friggin well I mean it's
really I'm really really proud now I'm
starting to see it it's all coalescing
it's all coming together and I can't
wait for everybody to see it it's really
working out well you guys heard it here
first it's coming together well you
heard it here first I want to know what
it is like for you guys to work together
what's your process like how ahead of
the conversations go well I mean we're
honestly we're friends I mean and I got
to know Andy years ago when I was
working in the bad offices and then like
we went on a cruise and played craps
that was I think our process is is
really um is really similar to the way I
work with Greg or Raphael where I like
to find out how the person I'm working
with likes to likes to communicate with
with me
and then kind of work that way and
luckily with Andy he loves to get on the
phone
we'd love to talk it through love's like
loose outline a bit so I get to be a lot
more flexible and just focus on the
emotions focus on the action focus on
the the feeling of each scene and then
his storytelling is so immaculate that I
trust him that the more rope I give him
the
or you know he's just gonna kind of take
it and do better than I could so we I
mean we talked a lot about it like we
got it it's a true collaboration it
really is and it's not like you know
okay here's the script go and do it
you know I we talked it out especially
with the way Scott's doing the plots and
the scripts there's a lot of room for me
to put into into it what I do and that
makes it a lot more fun for me and it's
just the whole project just it makes it
that much more I guess better a good
working relationship and a friendship
sounds like somebody like this you can't
not mean you you can't be it it's
awesome one more plug also for there's
one other person who's been helping me
on the series with these dark matter
books like and I'm doing Batman in the
signal as well you know I've had such
just such a great time of TC and had the
opportunity to you know bring a lot of
new concepts and new kind of characters
to the line I really wanted this to be
sort of a runway for some of the
students that I've taught in the talent
development workshop because it they're
so good and it's such an honor to be
able to do that so with signal I'm
bringing in Tony Patrick to help me and
with challengers and we're bringing in
Aaron Gillespie who's a young writer
who's really fantastic so I'm writing it
you know with him but it's also an
opportunity for him to start to get his
feet wet at DC you know the story is
something I've been planning a long time
and and you know I sort of pitched it to
him and I went through it so it's still
it's still the concept and the writing
or the story that I wanted to do but it
it allows sort of the way I brought in
James Tainan or Marguerite you know it
allows them to kind of learn I think the
the the architecture of a kind of
superhero script all that stuff on the
fly without with a bit of a safety net
so I'm really really proud of the work
he's done as well I just wanted to give
him a shout out and he's here at the con
at some point yeah so hopefully we'll
get started and I just want to give one
a shout out while you're shouting out
the guys that are working with me on the
are on challengers Klaus Janson on class
Ryan Anderson they both working with me
on Dark Knight 3 so I'm dragging them
over to challengers and I didn't have to
drag them they all both said absolutely
there's a Klaus you have to drag out of
the house
I'm surprised he's here he's like he was
on the cruise too and like you'd see him
in the morning and then in his cabin so
many different things how do you keep
them straight how do you
compartmentalize them it really is each
one is honest I know it sounds hokey but
each one is a dream project like
challenger's is a special book to me I
literally pitched it when I was one year
in a DC in a slightly different format
but the same spirit you know with metal
it's something I've been building to
with Greg for three years and you know
some of the stuff I have coming with
Shaun Murphy and that at the Batman
story that we've been planning a while
same thing each one is just so different
than the other and there's they're not
like books where Dan or Jim or Jeff said
hey we need this it was more what do you
want to do and trying to figure out a
project like for this it's just complete
fun complete dynamism with him and I get
to bring in you know a new writer and so
they're all so different that I can kind
of compartmentalize them and be like
this week I'm doing this
next week I'm doing that if they were
similar like if it was writing you know
Batman and detective comics it would be
hard because they're each so unique I
just I don't have a hard time with that
because they're all organically singular
that is amazing I mean that sounds like
a dream to be honest with the jobs we
have they're not really jobs you know we
get to have a lot of fun and it pays
more you can't beat my kids literally
both put on their sheet they both want
to be writers and I was like why do you
want to be writers and they're like oh
it looks fun and and you stay in your
PJs all day dad you guys are so fun to
talk to and I cannot wait for this comic
that's all the time we have for this
interview okay guys we have so much more
stuff to get to stick around and we will
be back with more in DC goodness the
most celebrated graphic novel ever
Watchmen now The Watchmen characters in
the DC Universe come together for the
first time
DC proudly presents Doomsday Clock Geoff
Johns Gary Frank but twelve issue comic
book series get issue number wanted a
comic shop near you cyborg is making the
leap to the big screen in Justice League
but he's also rocking it in his solo
comic series we've got writer John
Sanford here to tell us all about it
hey John hey how are you thank you for
having me let's talk about cyborg 17 it
just hits shelves and tell us all about
what's going on with it well throughout
the entire I'm gonna say 19 issue arc
that I've done it's been building and
building and building and finally we are
getting to the end issue 18 will be the
end issue 17 as the end of one major
phase of it cyborg is now trapped in an
alternate reality that's really a
virtual reality everyone there thinks
they're real and he has come up against
his doppelganger his virtual reality
doppelganger and he's learning a lot
about himself just by dealing with this
character and it's all coming to a head
so it really can't get any more exciting
than that oh yeah yeah well it's kind of
I love pitting cyborg with people that
kind of elicit humor from him and from
them you know sort of Odd Couple
pairings and it's kind of a strange and
funny odd-couple pairing they love
shooting puns at one another and they're
kind of getting to know one another and
of course for the fans it's fun to see
them interacting in this situation
knowing that they've interacted before
in other incarnations so I think it's
it's a fun element
that sounds really sweet yeah so let's
talk about these there's these big
events happening right now there's metal
there's Doomsday Clock how does your
story
how's your story affected by these big
events delightfully not at all really
I've been allowed to play in my own
sandbox so yeah I'm not
no one's no one's held a gun to my head
made me do anything plot wise yeah it's
really fun as a creative person I feel
like that's the best thing this has been
very good to me and I want to thank Jeff
Jones and my editors for allowing me to
really go wild and go crazy
I hope enjoying it you're watching this
definitely so thank you so you've been
writing cyborg for a while now what's
been your favorite part of writing this
character my favorite part is getting a
comic book when when it comes in the
mail when I get my comps I think the
thing you strive for as a creator is to
see something of yourself and your
creations and I've done a lot of work in
television I've done a lot of work in
animation and that has its charms but
you always kind of feel like there's
some element of that that's done by
committee comic books for me are very
intimate you know it's it's storytelling
on a very intimate level
I am I I'm very proud when I get the
comic book I feel like it reflects the
way I think the way I write I've been
working with some marvelous artists
right now I'm working with wil Conrad
who is just wonderful he's a great guy
and he's a great artist and he's a
really good logical extension of
everything I'm doing creatively so Noah
my favorite part is getting the new
comic book in the mail and reading it
about a hundred times and marveling and
how brilliant I am that's everybody's
favorite part
well that's true okay so issue 18 is
coming up can you give us a little bit
on what is to come in that is issue 18
wraps up everything I've been building
toward throughout the entire 19 issues
that I've been writing so issue 18 is
titled the end it is the end of this
particular saga it really it's the
culmination of just everything cyborgs
state of mind and his relationship with
all the characters around him especially
the new ones that I've created so it's a
big bang-up climax and I'm really
thrilled with the way it turned out we
know cyborg is gonna be on the big
screen with the Justice League I want to
ask you is there anything that you're
hoping to see from this tone I think the
thing that I tried to bring to cyborg
was a certain humanity that maybe wasn't
explored before I hope that that turns
up not only in the movie but in every
other incarnation of cyborg from now on
I would love to see just a kind of my
little contribution to his state of mind
and his vulnerability and his sense of
humor I would like to see some of that
turn up but I also just want people to
really appreciate how wonderful this
character is he's a great character and
you know apart from anything I've done I
hope that people really enjoy that film
and and really want to know more about
him after that you guys make sure you
pick up this fantastic art go see
Justice League obviously we know you're
gonna thank you so much for taking the
time with me today thank you for having
me on your show show you guys New York
Comic Con keeps getting better and
better and we'll be right back after
this message
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back
now the flash has a long story in
history and here to tell us about the
next chapter of the fastest man alive is
the fastest rider alive Joshua
Williamson how are you sir I'm doing
really great man having a good time here
at a New York Comic Con how is the fan
reaction to your run on the flash bin
here at New York Comic Con oh man it's
been really great people come up and we
get to talk about the flash you know I'm
a flash Tran - you know so when people
come out we get to talk about I asked
them to pair of flashes we have these
like nice conversations and I always
tell my give you guys anything you want
to talk about the flash I'm always here
to talk about it and so it's been really
great I've been asking people who their
favorite flashes and I was interesting
with this 108 secrets again the boss
[Laughter]
sure no spoilers
no more spoil yeah all right all right
all right so what's the biggest flaw in
the flash you can tell me right now am I
looking around like let's actually talk
about metal alright you got a bat out of
hell
metal tie-in starts later in the flash
what can you tell us about it so with
metal we've been doing this really big
event with Scott Snyder and Greg Capullo
it's called Dark Knight's metal we all
call it metal and in that event there
are these things are called the Dark
Knight's and each one represents one of
Bruce Wayne's worst fears in a series of
books called the dark the dark knight
one-shots and we're coming out the one
that I did that was the Red Death the
first one I did was called the Red Death
and it's a story about Batman actually
killing the flash to steal Speed Force
powers and what happens because of that
what drives into that well now we've did
one we did one event called the Gotham
resistance and then now we're doing a
new one that's coming out really soon
and it's called bats out of hell and
basically it starts off in flash three
three Strom bhai reporter and really
what it basically comes down to you is
it's the Justice League versus those
dark nights
it's them going out to each other into
it so it's a big fight so it's a fight
for four issues between these two groups
you have to imagine with a bat out of
hell each one of those dark nights
they're not each one of them is Bruce
Wayne Yeah right so in a lot of ways
just think is going up against seven
Bruce Wayne's were evil is talking about
is yes
it's gonna be tough before and the art
that's up on there right now yeah that's
from Howard Porter
that's from flash 33 it's amazing how
reporter is one of my favorite artists
I've been following since he was on the
Ray to do the underwater Unleashed JLA
like he did the flash with Jeff - and
and he's one of my hair artists so I've
been really thankful to work with him
and I mean look at that art it's so good
I want to give a major shout out to
Howard Porter as well because yeah he is
one of the best DC artists of the last
20 years
Bar None and I feel even kind of a see
your weapon like I don't know know about
him as much but he is amazing and I love
working with him and I'm excite people
to see this issue now fans are really
digging the metal event what is it like
for you as the writer does it expand the
world of DC does it make it more fun
than usual yeah I mean that's a big part
of it you know I think we've been
talking about this weekend and you know
Dan told me no spoilers but I'll totally
want to spoilers yeah but you know any
things we've been talking about a lot is
we really want to show people that the
DC Universe is much bigger than you
think you know there's a lot more pieces
like we think we know the DC Universe
and a lot of the characters in the DC
Universe they think they know what's up
the Justice League think they know all
the corners that they know all the
secrets a part of metal is I'm finding
out that's it's a way bigger than they
thought there's a lot more going on out
there's a lot of things I didn't know
about and this is really a taste of that
yeah what's going on a metal with
Barbara toe so everything has just a
taste
now you have a new arc in the flash
starting in issue 34 can you tell us a
bit about what is going on with Barry
and Wally in it well this won't Barry's
been going kind of a dark time after
everything happened with Thawne back
over the summer and so really the story
we're doing right now is trying to get
him out of that dark time and part of
getting him out of that is Barry
realizing he needs to be around both
Wally's you know he needs to be around
kids flash and Wally he needs that they
bring out the best in him and being
around iris but he knows he needs to get
back in a place where he can do that but
one of things that happen to him in that
last arc was he got transferred to iron
Heights and so now he has to work at
iron Heights that makes his job a lot
harder being only a CSI but also being
the flash put some challenges on it yeah
and so we're doing this story about how
he has to try and navigate all of that
and then we're gonna have a story that's
getting us out of the negative stuff
into it you know we're doing a story
after that called a cold day in hell and
it's about it's about Barry in iron
Heights and having to deal with the
Rogues and iron ice now I want to ask
you you write a flash book of course
flash books have many legacy characters
you have Kid Flash you have the other
Wally West just normal flash and Barry
Allen flash isn't
our view is the rider to juggle these
multiple flashes not because they're all
so different from each other you know I
mean they're a family so I see them as a
family and each kind of fill a role in
that family and in the end sometimes you
know sometimes berries that there's a
patriarch and sometimes Wally Wally is
the leader and the main figure there
mm-hmm classic original wallet yes and
then you know and then Kid Flash is sort
of he's new to everything everything is
open in this world and he really loves
being a superhero and so with each
character because they're so different I
it's not hard at all I guess you know
but I love I think the best way to write
them is when they're together I mean
that is my favorite like time to write
them that's where you can actually are
true in flash family yes yes under the
family we haven't got quite the flash
family yeah we're trying to get there
you're the flash family oh well you can
get me in trouble
really good huh but let me ask you this
if you could pitch a spin-off book
called the flash family would you do it
I can't say anything else right now
that's a yes everyone out there now
where can people find you on social
media they want to keep up with the
flash and everything you're doing with
me in the flash the best way to get me
is on Twitter and I Williams to
underscore Josh nice go read the flash
Josh Williams an excellent guy and if a
jam-packed live show from New York
comic-con isn't enough for you you need
to check out DC's New York Comic Con
sweepstakes neither of us can enter it
but you should because the prize pack is
massive massive excuse me
with all kinds of exclusive goodies and
for your chance to win submit your entry
at DC NY sweeps dot-com now we've got
more show to come I'm not letting Joshua
go anywhere because he wants to stay
around for a look inside the new Batman
versus two-face animated movie just like
you do with the filmmakers and Robin
Burt Ward but first hey Josh you're
gonna watch that just like trailer again
let's do it
yeah we're not right now
[Music]
[Music]
I'll take that as a yes what the ring
[Music]
good morning after the death of Superman
violence acts of war and terrorism are
all on the rise I had a dream it was the
end of the world
I think it's something more something
darker
[Music]
we're asking people we'd unknown to risk
their lives strong man and strong as
alone ever heard that it's my saying
that's the opposite of what the saying
is
divided we are not enough
worldly Superman
promise
why I brought you together right ain't
over yet man
[Music]
Oh awesome as a bad thing oh that's your
oh sorry
it's your signal that means we have to
go now yeah it's so cool that new
trailer is awesome but if you need more
Justice League in your life you should
check out the Justice League movie
statues from DC collections we've got
Batman and Wonder Woman and cyborg right
here and we've got Jim Fletcher not as a
statue but as a real-life he's gonna
document him now he's a little bit of
both a little mix to talk to us about
the collectibles these are incredible
yes yeah the detail on these is what we
really were happy about at the end of
the day there was so much work put into
the even on something like Wonder
Woman's shield you can hardly see it but
up close there's actually a there's an
eagle on here they can it's was so
battle damage than worn it's supposed to
look like it's been used a lot of times
stuff like that's what we really focused
on all the line work and cyborg actually
if you turn them around that's why you
can see do it there you go
slowly he's got a few things before I'm
a toy collector this is OK on the back
there's so much cool detail in here and
building I'm glad you pointed at that
definitely cuz building that out was
really tricky because there's not much
in there if you can see almost right
through it wires on his knees are very
amazing it's like I can stick this card
through there yeah 32 produced this was
really interesting we had talks with the
filmmakers who look at all this stuff
we're making it to make sure it's as
accurate as it as it can be and this we
were having talking about how we're
gonna actually produce this as it's so
small and has to hold up this whole
statue so that was an interesting
challenge but submits the plastic and
resident electorates alright now as a
collector or myself one of the things I
love the DC collectibles does especially
with their statutes they always throw in
nice little odds and ends in there and
you did this with the Batman V Superman
statues and you're doing again where we
have
poseable cage look look how big this is
you type that in there we go this Cape
is freaking huge
it's so good I mean I almost take it off
and use it yourself
yeah might be a big cake a nice play bit
but it's nice elector because you're not
locking us to one view you're letting us
be like well I want to look like he's
jumping and there's a pretty thick wire
in here yeah just you can pose it around
you can actually loop it like this go
for shoulder you can see more the detail
- yeah which is really cool so you hold
it up and in the back you've got all the
belt pieces and the straps get a look at
the back look at the details have been
waiting it's what I've been waiting for
this entire segment is a reveal it is
what is fertile in this was a reveal of
the Batman revealing their true nature
perhaps obviously are for the Justice
League film so the detailing even the
costumes and everything but the faces of
the actors how much how much time goes
into making sure that they look as much
as they can like me that's the most
challenging part that's a great question
because that's when really have to get
in there and we were looking at people's
faces all day and we're studying them
and trying to see what works and what
doesn't and James Marciano especially we
did the Wonder Woman piece was great he
we had to do that face about two or
three times before it was actually
completed and Debbie and Zak were very
you know they look at everything they're
very particular about what they think
looks right as well and even though
these are from digital files and
stand-in you still have to clean them up
yeah just that you'll just get the files
and pop them out and go there's your
face because there's a lot of nuances
and some of them I mean scope does
somebody like Batman pretty you know
this bat chin how much also goes into
the decision of what each pose each
character is going to do is that like
story based yeah well sometimes yes and
sometimes no I mean I know what cyborgs
pose I am sure there's a part we
standing around like that yep you might
even be like a shot we've just be oh
that's what we got something like that
the Batman pose though was interesting
so we didn't know that much about this
when we first started it so we had to go
in and talk to
deciders and be like what what's he
doing like yeah so we actually have my
favorite picture I have is Zach posing
as Wonder Woman for us actually not this
particular one but not that movie statue
from the one the other movie where he
actually was got into a pose I'm like
what you supposed to be doing he gets
into this like post we have pictures on
them as Wonder Woman special one just
for him that everybody wants that yeah
so but yet for Batman we we had this in
this case it sent some drawings in I
scribbled out some stuff and posed a
couple of X action figures and say does
this kind of work for what he's wearing
in this attitude so that's it's either
that or it's a scene from the movie that
we get to see you will use that
so before we let you go I gotta know
when can I get my hands on these how
much allowance do I need to save don't
assemble the whole Justice League in my
house
well you look we just got your hands on
them cuz they're right here how easy
hold me that I get to have them glossy
canon cameras on them that's a little
different you know what I meant kid you
know what I meant okay that's why well
some of them are they're coming in now
they're actually should be in stores in
November so that's that's pretty quick
like they were coming out right before
the show and they're all here for
everybody seeing them and there are a
hundred and fifty bucks apiece so I mean
for the detail and everything that
Jimmy's it's it's a great representation
of all the characters and one more
interesting thing I want to point out on
all their skin isn't actually painted
it's actually cast in a tinted resin wow
they look so so real that's almost
that's not translucent but if you look
at it there's no paint the only things
like around their eyes in their face and
everything it's like our skin you know
made out of resin yep last question
obviously we've got the three of them
here but what are we gonna happen we're
gonna have the whole team yes there may
be some other characters coming out yet
Aquaman looks amazing he's got this
whole freakin suit of armor on this
great the flash is also coming out and
that's an interesting one cuz the
costume design was very common for
details
yeah really interesting to get all the
little things painted on all of them so
that was that was he was challenging to
produce
but you'll definitely be seeing those
and maybe some other ones yes there's
also a certain I believe but alien from
space that's your I believe coming out
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you so much for geeking out with
us about these sleek statues they look
amazing and don't you go anywhere we are
hurling towards our epic finale and
you're gonna have to stick around to see
how it all ends we'll be right back
there's unleashed a new trailer for
Justice League at San Diego comic-con
that gave us our first clues as to what
we can expect from the big bad
Steppenwolf
comic readers recognize Steppenwolf as
one of the most powerful beings the
Justice League could go up against so
we're pulling out our back issues to
answer the question who is Stefan wolf
first and foremost Steppenwolf is one of
the New Gods a cast of characters
introduced into the DC Universe by
legendary artist Jack Kirby's the
immortal new gods belong to Kirby's
fourth world which exists beyond the
realm of normal space and time they
inhabit two planets new genesis ruled by
the benevolent high father and
apocalypse home of the evil overlord
Darkseid and you guessed it Steppenwolf
has been playing for Team apocalypse
since his first appearance in New Gods
number seven in 1972 seven wolf is
Darkseid's uncle and he commands the
military forces of apocalypse with
ruthless ferocity he's known for leading
Darkseid's deadly dog Cavalry which is
comprised of warriors riding massive
canines and his signature weapon is the
electro axe plus as a new god
Steppenwolf has superhuman strength
speed and endurance in Steppenwolf's
debut he murdered highfather wife which
launched a war between new Genesis and
apocalypse the grief-stricken leader
eventually tracked Steppenwolf down and
killed him but years later
Steppenwolf was revived and appointed to
lead Darkseid's army in 1984 is New Gods
number six beyond that Steppenwolf
helped Darkseid escape from doomsday in
1995's doomsday annual and is no
stranger to battling justice leaguers
taking on the flash Green Lantern Black
Canary and Arsenal in 2007 the flash the
fastest man alive
number nine in the new 52 Steppenwolf
invaded earth to with a massive army of
Darkseid's parademons the apocalyptan
forces killed Wonder Woman and Superman
in battle and Batman had to sacrifice
themselves in order to send the
parademons back to the hellish planet
they came from most recently at
Steppenwolf appeared in the Dark Side
war storyline as one of Darkseid
soldiers and in battle against the
anti-monitor
the Justice League will have to bring
their a-game if they want to stand
against Steppenwolf this fall because
there's no doubt that the new God will
unleash the full power of apocalypse
we're so excited to see the battle hit
the big screen this November what's that
ticking I hear that's right it's time to
beat the Doomsday Clock
beat the Doomsday Clock is a game our
fans try to answer five questions about
the DC Universe yeah what's that for us
yeah there's cheering back there I'm
just gonna go with it you've got 30
seconds to answer 5 DC questions
correctly and we might just have a super
cool prize for you to get them right so
let's welcome our first contestant come
on out here come on over here of course
we have to start with a Wonder Woman I
love it so much what's your name where
you from Sandra where are you from sound
so you didn't come too too far to come
in to Comic Con today I was thought you
were gonna say I came from the mascara I
should have said Paradise Island you
know you got the costume on and you look
great so how confident do you feel about
this game ok all right so you have 2
categories that you can pick from would
you like to answer questions about the
Justice League or about Wonder Woman
will do Wonder Woman Wonder Woman
alright so you have 30 seconds to answer
as many of these questions right as you
can hopefully we'll get all five we'll
see how this goes I have confidence I'm
gonna count you in are you ready to beat
the clock
yes all right ready let's do it
Wonder Woman wield the lasso of truth
yes where is Wonder Woman from the
mascara
what is Wonder Woman's real name Diana
she was the founder woman's main love
interest oh gosh I don't remember his
name okay well what is the name of
Wonder Woman's people who lives on the
mascara
women yes they there is warriors you can
order a lot of stuff from this place
Amazon yes they are the yes you got it
you got it for me time is up you got
four out of five correct awesome job you
know I mean
five for the [ __ ] all right right yeah
okay so we like to have everybody leave
here feeling really really good even if
they only got four out of five right but
you came in the costume so you're not
going home empty-handed thank you how do
you feel about taking this beautiful
lady home with you my heart is pumping
well you get do you wonder Wonder Woman
collectible I am gonna delicately hand
this off to you I don't want to break it
before I even give it to her and I won't
take this back from you
congratulations be very delicate with
her all right so she did pretty well
four out of five four out of five and
two bad all right well let's bring in
our next contestant come on out here you
look awesome
I love it come on over move a little bit
over here I want you to a little bit
closer what is your name and where you
from okay my name is Raisa and I'm from
the Caribbean Trinidad you wait did you
come from Trinidad to come to this con
oh no I moved there from by probably 13
years ago
okay come that far but I'm sure you came
pretty far in this costume yeah thank
you thank you so you got to see our
first contestant go yeah do you feel
confident that you can beat the clock ah
well I am a speech stuff so let's see if
I could do that good answer good answer
I like it okay so you can either answer
questions about the Justice League or
about the Suicide Squad I would say
Justice League
okay Justice League you're gonna have 30
seconds to see if you can beat the claw
I just like saying it that way the
countdown is about to start are you
ready ready all right let's do it
name two members of the Justice League
Superman and well the flash good name
two more members two more members Batman
and Green Lantern crushed it not in the
movie but yeah we'd never know who plays
that one in the upcoming Justice League
movie Ben Affleck yes what is the name
of the Justice League's headquarters
ah they look okay next one what villain
did the Justice League fight in their
first comic book appearance was it
doomsday time is up but we're gonna get
we're gonna get you to this last one
okay in this sky at night they're our
size and sometimes if someone surprised
you you'd be like shucks
oh my goodness yeah yeah okay the first
word so put it together oh my this is
turning into charades here on v6 ha
meet the Doomsday Clock I love it so
much you did a great job thank you thank
you we got you to four out of five so I
guess since we already gave someone else
surprise before out of five how do you
feel about taking a little you know
collectible home for yourself I feel
about it all right bring in the prize
you sure get to go home with a flash
collectible check out this statue thank
you very much you're so welcome
all right we're gonna bring in another
contestant and who knows maybe I'll do
more charades I don't know I want them
to do a good job and I'm willing to help
come on out here hello Aquaman here's
your microphone what do you do
Oh Christian Garcia I really thought you
were gonna say Arthur
nice to meet you you look great
thank you what made you choose Aquaman
the moment they hired Jason Momoa to
play Aquaman I already kind of got the
vibe going down how do you feel about
your beat the Doomsday Clock chances he
was good
oK we've got four out of five so far all
right see if we can get you to five out
of five so your two categories sir our
Suicide Squad
or Aquaman Aquaman good choice are you
ready yeah okay let's get that doomsday
clock ticking and yo first question
Aquaman is king of what underwater
Kingdom and
this Aquaman can telepathically
communicate with what fish yes
what does Aquaman's real name Arthur
curry yes what are the classic colors of
Aquaman's costume
I think it's orange and green yes what
Aquaman lost his hand what did he
replace it with oh my god with like 10
seconds to spare crushed it
congratulations man
okay so I'm not even be like only people
give you a prize maybe we won't we're
definitely giving you a prize for that
and I feel like we've got the perfect
one Aquaman now you can get like all
up-close in this costume so next time
you're like it's gonna look just like
this one right Yeah right
yes congratulations awesome job dude I
just like giving people prizes it's
really fun so I feel like maybe we could
do I don't know one more contestant and
maybe it could be like a surprise
celebrity guest I don't know come on out
here
who do we got oh it's mr. Jason and how
do you feel about your chances to beat
the Doomsday Clock I feel good I'm a
little concerned you stole my game show
I I was just borrowing it so that way
you could come out and be a contestant I
wanted to give you a taste of your own
medicine all right
no I feel like you've been testing
people so much so it's your turn and you
know I'm not even gonna give you a
choice with the category because we are
choose Kyle Rayner Mary Lantern nope
nope nope nope nope I choose Dick
Grayson Nightwing because we made you
Simone okay little bit harder question
right les I know how your DC knowledge
is okay all right you ready for this I'm
ready for this Tiffany don't look at the
cards Jason I can't see the car I don't
have x-ray vision to get that Doomsday
Clock ready are you ready yes let's do
this all right I'm gonna focus in do it
first question of what number Lantern
secretaries earth in two eight one four
oh my god what is the title of that of
the batman the animated series episode
that reimagined mr. freeze heart is ice
cold as ice close cuz what are the names
of both Wonder Woman's parents Zeus and
Hippolyta what year did the Wally West
flash solo series begin ninety-two 87 86
yes
cyborg was created by which writer in
our Wolfman and George breast okay we're
gonna go back to Batman the Animated
Series it was called ice heart is ice
give me a handle tonight part of ice
[Applause]
that was impressive I mean I feel like I
knew that you had a lot of DC knowledge
but this was this is a very good showing
just wait till you see me do the Kyle
Rayner trivia next time so I feel like
you know I should give you something
because you did such a good job right do
I get this microphone No Oh get that
microphone we can give you like you a
it's the best thing you're a comic-con
ever you know what your prize is what
think you get to host this show that's
the prize that keeps giving and I'm
seriously I'm gonna take this microphone
off it's the best yeah
I've been good safe to say that DC has
some pretty pretty incredible fans and
thank you guys all they who played the
games with us Jason I'm so impressed by
all of your knowledge and how just your
cosplay to guys yeah coming up next we
have the filmmakers and cast behind the
newest animated Batman adventure of
Batman versus two-face
we'll be right back I'll find you a
better prize
instigate the extractor protocol I have
a bad feeling about this
behold my evil extractor
dear times over ends a machine with
their even it's down
[Music]
it's a double cross all signs pointing
to two-face I won't rest until we get to
the bottom of this the game is afoot mr.
dent get the lead out or I'll put them
later
I can't go on like this I insist you
stop this madness not pretty boy we had
a deal going once going twice sold to
all the villains of Gotham
soon the seeker will be exposed for all
of Gotham to see to the Batmobile
start side up get the boys
you'll never take me alive keep coppers
Barbie stay strong
wakey-wakey bird boy now it's your turn
Robin the boy gimme Pig you'll never
figure out how to use that without Hugo
Strange you know what they say if your
catechism in the heart of a lab
experiment joins n Batman versus
two-phase perfectly captures the fun of
the sixties famine and that is only
possible with the help from these fine
gentlemen over here co-writers Michael
jellinek and James Tucker guys thank you
so much for joining today thanks for
having us so let's talk about the
premise of Batman versus to face
well the premises is right in the title
it's Batman voices to face out be
self-explanatory yeah I think the fun of
this is who's playing Batman who's
playing to face Adam West versus William
Shatner it's awesome what can you tell
us about two faces evil plot well that'd
be a spoiler but let's just say he's
challenging
Batman's ideas about friendship and
loyalty because two-face is Harvey Dent
and two-face Harvey Dent and Bruce Wayne
are best friends and so the story is
really about Batman wanting to trust his
friend and thinking his friend has
reformed himself but the mystery is Ozzy
or hesitant you know and so that brings
tensions out between those characters in
between Batman and Robin and you have to
see yeah I can't wait and you guys also
incorporate Harleen Quinzel into this
what was it like incorporating her into
the 60s world she gets a little cameo we
don't we don't we don't make her
full-blown Harley want to call it Harley
Quinn and or is dr. Harleen pretty it's
definitely weird to have her in this
version of that it seems a little
unnatural but yeah but we definitely
make nods to her relationship with the
Joker
her future relationship with the Joker
we should say and there's a little
Easter egg on the disc that shows more
of that but you'll see when you get the
disc but it's really cool it's a little
nod to Batman the Animated Series even
though I really don't think Cesar Romero
is Joker would be that interested in
Harley but well I love the idea to have
William Shatner as your face did you
guys know that you wanted that from the
beginning pretty much yeah I don't think
we would have done this project without
Shatner so it's like it's a Shatner or
nothing it was great he's he he's
definitely William Shatner and all that
entails what we were hoping that we
would really just bring his AGame
and really bring a lot of vitality and
that's what he always brings to most of
the parts he plays and we also wanted it
to feel like it was happening right then
in 1966 so the person he was in 1966 the
actor he was in 1966 paired with Adam
West and he delivered taking like the
two most iconic actors from the two most
iconic shows of all time I mean
comic-con is like because of these guys
Adam West's final performance that's so
special tell me what you guys think
about his impact on the character about
it
well it's indelible I mean other people
had played Batman before him but no one
remembers those guys so I mean if he had
gotten it wrong
even though a lot of people complain
about the camp eNOS of the show but if
he had failed if he had not made that
such a success we may not even be
talking about Batman right now right do
you guys have any special memories that
you can share working with him yeah I
know for me last year at Comic New York
Comic Con we got to spend the day
together got to see what kind of person
he was he was so full of energy such an
entertainer
it really loved his fans so I was hoping
to be able to experience that again this
comic-con fortunately it wasn't going to
be but we're glad that this is how he
gets to go out you know playing Batman
so much for taking the time I know you
got to hop back on the plane so thank
you for taking some time with me today
guys we were coming right back with
writer producer James Tucker and Robin
himself Burt Ward buddy here's here's
the exclusive look at Batman versus to
face the Ptolemaic jewel thank goodness
you've come Batman it's that
megalomaniacal miscreant from
Mesopotamia King Tut him again this time
he stolen an irreplaceable biplane he's
a man to be pitied
the struggles he must face as a man
divided but justice is a firm but fair
mistress and come to justice he will I
am so excited to welcome to the stage
director red Morales and a man who needs
no introduction the Boy Wonder himself
Burt Ward how's it going guys great how
are you dear fantastic it's Sunday my
voice is almost gone but I'm so happy to
be here talking to you guys that's nice
to be here with a few people that are
here at this comic-con just it just a
sprinkling of in so I cannot wait for
this movie and I want to know Rick what
was your inspiration my inspiration was
to do a sequel to the first one
I think I think one of the greatest
things about this is know going into it
we knew that William Shatner was going
to be involved we knew who the villain
well you know like very early on like
when we were in the process of making
the first one and just the excitement of
getting to work with Burt Ward and Adam
West and William Shatner it's just
incredible so it was really a lot of fun
that's amazing in Burt
tell us about Robins character in this
well Robins character doesn't change you
know people keep saying well what did
you do to prepare for this and and you
have to understand when I first got the
role in 1966 they had interviewed 1,100
young actors for the role the executive
producer came to me said Burt he said
the reason we picked you is because in
our minds if there wasn't a television
show but there was a real Robin you
would be it so we want you to be
yourself don't quote act just be
yourself and be enthusiastic which is
what I did for 120 episodes in several
movies so it isn't something different
to be yourself you know and Robin you
know is perennial you know all-american
apple pie and that's exactly how I play
it that's but so it makes so much sense
I know I thought like in this one in
particular one of the most exciting
things about it was you actually did
kind of get to go someplace a little
different than yes that is true
that is true yes that was thanks to Rick
and the other writers who gave us the
material to do something a little bigger
and a little more different than what we
did in the 60s
okay let's talk about Shatner what was
it like working with him that must have
been so much fun
it was incredible I mean unfortunately
you guys didn't record together like I I
wish you would have been able to do that
no that's true but but I I see Bill out
on the on the circuit eye because I go
to the Comic Cons and sign autographs
and I when I when I saw his stuff or at
least a part of his stuff it was just
brilliant I mean he really does an
amazing job he's a great actor and he is
shines in this movie and a casting I
mean think about this way the two most
iconic television shows in history our
Batman
Star Trek so you put the two together
you know with the actors working
together I mean that's a real dynamic
demo it's very strong and it made so
much sense and one of the coolest parts
about it was going to William Shatner's
voice record and and seeing him for the
first time start to speak in with his to
face voice you know you don't really
know what to expect where he's going to
take it and is there going to be some
sort of direction that he's going to
have to be given to he did it and it was
like oh man that's amazing
perfect he made it easy for you well
this is obviously a very special movie
because this is Adam West's last
performance as Batman can you guys speak
on what you think his contribution to
the character of that let me just say
this you know we have to understand back
when we made our show comic books were
popular but they weren't real popular
okay and our show did something
different what we did was the first
television show in history where the
actors actually put the audience on if
you watched a police show was you know
apprehending a villain or a medical show
healing somebody but nobody ever teased
the audience played with the audience
double meanings all is suggestive stuff
while at the same time keeping it all
American apple pie for the kids hero
worship riding in the Batmobile climbing
the walls
fighting heinous villains and yet at the
same time with these double meanings and
stuff that the college kids and the kids
in high school and the adults absolutely
loved and what's really cool is the
people that were kids then as they grew
up and their children were watching it
they were watching it and seeing a whole
different side to it
multifaceted I mean when I was a kid it
we took it deadly serious and my sister
and I would watch and you see the
cliffhanger and you'd be like how are
they going to get out of this one like
there's no way they're going to escape
this like and then and then of course
you know you guys always did it and and
then and then you watch it as an adult
and you're like
we're kind of gurnie you guys thank you
so much for taking the time with me I
know that you are busy you got a lot of
exclusives to go by a lot of swag that
you need to get so thank you for taking
the time Thank You citizen you guys the
show is not over yet we have another
look inside a brand new title from DC
Comics so do not move a muscle
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
Green Lantern is joining the family of
earth-1 titles and this is a Hal Jordan
like you've never seen before we're so
happy to have Gabriel Hardman and Karina
Beco here to join us thanks for coming
see Co Isis live thank you for having us
now what is Green Lantern earth one
about can you tell us a little about the
story it's it's a very sort of stripped
down sci-fi take on the Green Lantern
mythos where Hal Jordan finds he finds a
ring that that is not it's not given to
him it's not drawn to him it's it's it's
simply a a tool that he uses to go off
and and see a much bigger galaxy than I
ever realized existed now how will house
approach to ring Slean be different in
this universe than the normal superhero
universe where he basically just makes a
big boxy look well for one thing since
it is a tool that he finds and no one
has shown him how to use it and he
doesn't have a natural affinity for it
at first
yes actually learn how to use it it's
very difficult for him so it is
technology that he is not familiar with
but he is a very smart gifted guy so
he's in space space is dangerous things
happen you I mean if he you know if he
can't control the ring at first he could
die out there you know it's not there
there's a we're taking away an enormous
level of comfort there's no Green
Lantern Corps anymore you know it
existed in the past but he you know he
this is a these are all things that he
finds out along the way now you've made
how an astronaut what would you say are
the differences in running that type of
how compared to the fighter jockey pilot
how the the world were that he's in the
world he's any kind of defines it right
so he's like it does you know for any of
us and he so he has to be
being an astronaut is is something that
they do that should be an idealistic
sort of thing about exploration and and
as we start it the world is not in that
place anymore there's whole you know
there's no money and there's no there's
no interest in going out and exploring
and and and but I would say that there's
a lot of DNA shared between being the
the test pilot type of person and being
an astronaut because you still have to
at some point have gone through all that
training done things that are not in
your and what a normal person would do
but he's also he you know to be an
astronaut has to be a smart guy yes you
know have a lot of critical thinking I
don't know that that you know I mean
that could apply just as much to test
pilot Hal as well but I mean it's
something we're leaning into now let's
talk about a little bit of the visual
aspect of this book are you going for
your own tone because again this is very
different than the normal Green Lantern
that we're used to seeing I guess it is
I you know yeah I mean the tone is is
something that where we start very
naturalistic I mean in a way it's you
know we think of we thought about alien
a lot the first the Ridley Scott alien
because of just the you know Ripley and
everybody there they're like space
truckers you know there's a there's a
there's a kind of naturalism to that
even yeah working in space you know and
so I mean just for setting the initial
tone of it that's what we thought a lot
about but once he gets out out into the
the wider galaxy it's we're seeing you
know dramatically different things and
exotic things and things that you know
that we're it this is a very
point-of-view driven story it's not
there's not an acceptance that there's
this whole giant galaxies and planets
and aliens out there it's something he's
discovering and along with that I think
it changes a little we have a little bit
more fantastical elements Jordan Boyd
our color is displayed with that a
little bit absolutely
now you mentioned that the Green Lantern
Corps is not around but does that mean
we will not see any other lanterns
besides how no it does not mean that I
mean that I pulled it out of them all
right now is there a Green Lantern oath
in this book no you know there you put
the foot down you know to use it do you
have to say an oath no no there will be
now I will smash hit it hard yes I will
like we definitely we're kind of
consciously in a lot of ways going back
to the sort of even the Silver Age core
of it being a science fiction driven
yeah story that doesn't mean that there
was no oath in the past but maybe but
but a lot of those a lot of those
trappings aren't necessarily a part of
it because we wanted to take the you
know the most core things about the
character and about how how this world
works rather than than some of the
flourishes but that have evolved along
the way let's talk a little bit about
how your creative rich relationship
works like how do you write together how
do you work together how do you create
together how did this world come to be
well we're married so we live in the
same house so you just yell over to the
next room Hey we talk a lot of we talk
through these things endlessly and
develop the concepts and and we have a
fairly smooth flow now we've done
several volumes of our creator and image
book there's more public yeah and other
other properties so so it but but the
fact that we both write it and I draw it
means there's the if something isn't
quite working when on you know when I'm
drawing it we can I just walk upstairs
in my studio and we talk it yeah
well maybe the maybe there's a better
way to stage this or you know it's it
can be a very organic process because we
have the ability to do that as opposed
to creators who are who never talk to
each other or just via email or perhaps
don't even share a language I mean
that's been I've worked with a number of
people from Argentina or someplace than
where you're using Google Translate and
it adds an extra step where as we talk
about each other in the dead yes really
quickly the best thing about the earth-1
series is that anyone can jump into it
anybody out there that is not a fan of
green lantern what would you say to them
to make them pick up Green Lantern
earth-1 well this is just a this is an
accessible exciting sci-fi book that you
don't bring your preconceptions to it
like you know just just come for you
know for an awesome story that's gonna
there's gonna make you a Green Lantern
fan that has beautiful art Gabriel
Karina thank you so much for joining us
on DC all-access live our time is almost
up but stick around because the show
isn't over because we'll be right back
with even more cool stuff Dinah
[Music]
where are we we are the bridge to a
greater understanding
[Music]
right what is your mission you are in
more danger than you think
millions were dying and willing to fight
for those who cannot fight for
themselves who's this young woman dan
princess of lemon Prince Diana Prince
the perfect Wonder Woman
licensed with our and grace
he's all muscle and all heart because
there were sacred duty to defend the
world and it's what I'm going to do the
worldwide phenomenon your breath is over
becomes whole
you did this we did
[Music]
yep that's not gonna work please put the
sword down it doesn't go with the outfit
at all with an exclusive scene not shown
in theaters Wonder Woman all the digital
movie now has been such an awesome
weekend so thank you guys for hanging
out with us thanks again to all of our
amazing guests for giving us a look at
all the comics movies games collectibles
and animation coming up for the DC
Universe such such a good Comic Con be
sure to subscribe to the DC YouTube
channel where some of you are watching
right now and follow DC on instagram and
twitter using the handle at DC Comics I
think there's only one thing left for us
to do you guys watch the new Justice
League trailer three more times
[Music]
[Music]
I'll take that as a yes what the ring
[Music]
good morning after the death of Superman
violence acts of war and terrorism are
all on the rise I had a dream
and was the end of the world
you
[Music]
I think it's something more something
darker
[Music]
asking people we done know to risk their
lives strong man and strong is alone
never heard that it's not saying that's
the opposite of what the saying is
divided we are not enough
we'll be Superman
made him promise
why I brought you together ride ain't
over yet man
[Music]
Oh awesome as a bad thing oh that's your
sorry
it's your signal that means we have to
go now yeah I sort of mean it's so cool